et je reçois à présent jantes j'ai ma
bonsoir bonsoir le fondateur de la
compagnie black bombers accompagné de
danse de 50 ans en Yvelines qui a
contribué à développer la culture
hip-hop c'était au début des années 80
on parlera d'ailleurs plus en détail
tout à l'heure des 30 ans qui approchent
2014 pour cet anniversaire mais déjà
votre actualité c'est cette entrée de
Jean gimadoco Deski le Conseil de
développement de 50 ans en Yvelines et
que vient faire Jean de gemade au
codesqui alors on vient au codeski quand
on est nommé par le représentant d'une
collectivité locale ou territoriale en
l'occurrence là c'est le président
Robert kadalbert de la communauté
d'agglomération qui m'a nommé dans un
collège qui est un collège d'experts
l'idée d'abord qu'est-ce que le code
esquive pas mal de gens qui savent mais
c'est un conseil de développement disons
que c'est un organe qui existe depuis
que les codesquiers existent
c'est-à-dire depuis 10 ans ici à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et l'objectif
c'est de donner des conseils aux
politiques justement pour orienter la
population qui s'inquiète de la vie
politique responsable associative de
l'ensemble des grands sujets qui
touchent à la cité et qui porte conseil
la suggestions ouverture à l'ensemble de
nos élus voilà c'est ça le connais et
vous votre véritable volonté pour
apporter ces différentes recommandations
c'est d'expliquer qu'il faut donner du
corps de la chair c'est ce que vous
dites donnez une âme un petit peu
revenir richesse aux humains qui
existent dans ce territoire un bassin
peut pas se développer uniquement sur
l'aspect économique absolument et bon
j'incarne pas seul mais disons que le
fait de m'y avoir convié au bout de 10
ans
indique une inflexion une évolution à la
fois de la part de nos élus mais
certainement aussi de tout le milieu
associatif que j'incarne notamment celui
du spectacle vivant et des grandes
associations d'artistes qui sont nées
sur ce territoire de depuis le début
depuis presque 30 ans donc c'est cette
manière que par obligation les gens ont
eu de faire la ville eux-mêmes et donc
une ville qui n'était pas prescrite une
ville dans laquelle on était bon
peut-être quasiment obligé mais en même
temps très excité parce que on allait
construire quelque chose on allait on
allait un peu vers l'inconnu
on avait une sorte de rêve ça s'est
perdu mais pas qu'à 51 en Yvelines c'est
l'histoire de ces 30 dernières années
après les 30 glorieuses moins de moyens
plus de crises moins de rêve et à
Saint-Quentin aussi donc mon sentiment
c'est qu'il faut remettre du sens et du
rêve pour pas forcément l'atteindre mais
pour déjà fabriquer une sorte de commun
ce commun me paraît être le grand
déficit des travaux de ces dernières
années il faut que ça se fasse en
transversalité que tous les secteurs y
participent justement alors tout le
monde souhaite la transversalité mais
c'est souvent l'idée qu'il a permet qui
la rend possible c'est pas l'incantation
à la transversalité et donc j'ai suggéré
une idée à travers un terme qui est
l'art de vivre parce que l'art de vivre
me paraît être quelque chose où tout le
monde peut mettre
une idée une représentation et où tout
le monde peut apporter une amélioration
et je pense qu'après c'est quelque chose
qui peut s'organiser un petit peu par
lui-même mais qui va vraiment favoriser
une créativité à tous les niveaux de la
population c'est une nouvelle étape pour
vous dans cette relation avec ce
territoire où vous avez grandi
d'ailleurs vous avez construit des
choses depuis 30 ans plus tout à fait
c'est une nouvelle étape parce que je
pense que on arrive maintenant dans
après l'aménagement après l'installation
et puis montrer un peu ses muscles ce
qui était tout à fait naturel la crise
aidant ou à cause de la crise il va
falloir avoir plein d'idées être
inventif il va falloir s'adapter et
rechercher finalement le meilleur sens à
un art de vivre que tout le monde pourra
partager c'est ce que vous voulez
apporter donc au sein du codes qui en
aura l'occasion d'en
reparlerai sur ce thème vous allez
rester avec nous en plateau nous allons
passer à la chronique culture à présent
quelques questions à vous poser
justement avec cet anniversaire qui
approche bientôt 30 ans pour Black
bombers